hello and welcome to this video playing
I am gluten who is that Espen League ok
he plays Kings Indian and and similar
things so get a king's engineer a place
this for a long time and get haters on
the court against him already more than
once is 36 sort of going i believe whoa
ok a connector that can never be good
yes that that's just absolutely not
going to be ok but in let's just all
kind of nonsense might work I mean so
you should see home
so how do we do this now night beehive
doesn't work teen aged 80 this is his
plan yes maybe yeah ok let's try to be
quick
take a seven I know if it's good though
that's extremely messy stuff it
surprised that I isn't that good for
white I mean I don't get it we just play
the light like these are the most normal
ever and and drag it and remove
instantly I can even take what the f
porn habit I mean this is just good
right what's going to happen here takes
takes Queen geez heaven or what's the
point maybe that's the point yeah no not
the point he just goes into this
disastrous ending or what look see one
look see seven maybe eight game
so what do you could see 8 look see one
I even just have Luke see it coming them
and now it takes a long time that the
position is basically lost an hour let's
decide it's losing in them in a longer
time control em means you can play all
kinds of stuff let's just yeah just just
look CA but i can activate the King
first so create now
should win the ending okay honey
oh this is so cos it colored bishops him
I said that was David was I should have
thought about this I didn't pay any
attention anymore it's a bit silly that
allowed that okay I'm takes there and
the pawn should simply promote what
actually in town so I was extremely
unnecessary
you
I hope they actually winter if not that
would be quite frustrating well it could
be could be somewhat tricky if I just
take it and go to be five time running
too difficult to not do that okay I've
Danny's got f-35 and now I'm actually
threatening at a six so he has to go
back
wow that could have and I could have
done that so much easier it's beyond
words really mean it is winning but just
paying a bit of attention would have
helped blank region may I should never
allow that of course a Hindu sending
just just prevent the night from coming
like you a four or something what we
should primero yeah it for probably okay
i think it was winning but then it could
have done easier yeah I'm sorry if I'm a
little bit harsh sometimes and over this
is just this is just not working I mean
never yeah it might work in blitz if the
opponent played some little monsters but
it did sorry what is that plus 2 or
something when engine that's what I
expected something like win I mean and
of course yeah I mean all those pieces
are completely completely wrong I know
g4 was a very cautious move just block
everything then one didn't want to spend
too much time so yeah yeah I know this
was I just wanted to do something
quickly and not not that I'm not wait
for ages and then lose on time at the
end she won't be not the best c6 make
some sense them yeah it wasn't that
clear no I mean that was definitely true
yeah I don't know maybe avoid chief for
words when you have to be somewhat
practically okay he could have taken on
g4 taken on each one I was really
surprised that you continue to play all
those quick moves the calling the moment
my bishop arrives here that must be
fantastic if the ending is just lost I
think I just lost or close to lost
really bit strange but how how to refute
this completely are not g4 probably
queen bee three Bishop c4 a Foreman's I
don't know when this fear cannot believe
so like this and with the engine III
h3h3 we maybe hook a be one that's deep
I don't know if you can trust the
computer here look everyone it's strange
move okay I'm kind of still curious
about the ending so we're probably 85 85
is cooking I just wanted to bring the
king yes this was really unnecessary to
to allow it I think it still wins a five
is better okay but the things are still
willing to know yes it is whenever the
pawns promote adverse was wasn't a very
clean way of doing this ending but from
the wound in danger ok guys thanks for
watching
you